des téléviseurs des voitures volantes
des robots beaucoup de robots bienvenue
au consumer electronics show de las
vegas 4500 entreprises présentent leurs
gadgets cette semaine et du nombre des
centaines présente des robots de toutes
sortes
à commencer par le robot chairmen qui
vous apporte un rouleau de papier
génique sur commande lorsque vous êtes à
la salle de bain laure boulleau vote de
globex existe l'huile pour vous donner
des câlins d'autres sont plus utiles
comme le rugby qui guide les enfants
dans l'apprentissage de nouvelles
langues et il y à une série de robots
d'assistance comme bada de samsung qui
vous suit à la trace l'offre de gérer la
musique le chauffage et l'éclairage de
votre maison
ces innovations aussi amusante soit
elles sont loin d'être toutes promis à
un succès commercial
[Musique]